hello everyone and welcome to today's
arrived broadcast a keynote presentation
using sage to select for evolution of
reduced virulence in pathogenic bacteria
presented by dr. Paul Turner a professor
and departmental chair of ecology and
evolutionary biology at Yale University
and microbiology faculty member at Yale
School of Medicine I'm Suzy Valdez
Roberts and I'll be your moderator for
today's events we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labrys laborat is a leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appear on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also notice that you will be viewing
this presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem
good news this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits click on the button in
the bottom left hand corner and follow
the process to obtain your credits I
also want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
without any further ado let's join me in
completely welcoming dr. Paul Turner I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome dr. Turner hello I'm Paul
Turner from the department of ecology
and evolutionary biology at Yale
University and the microbiology graduate
program
School of Medicine today I'll present a
talk on using phage to select for
evolution of reduced virulence and
pathogenic bacteria and I'd like to
thank the organizers at lab roots for
allowing me to share the results of some
of our recent research with you so my
general interests in viruses
stem from a love of genetics genomics
and evolution under environmental change
and really the breadth of my research
program is shown in a slide like this if
you think about viruses and where they
exist in the ecosystem they have kind of
a problem they don't have a lot of
control over where they will go at any
one time so a virus is pretty much its
it needs to interact with a metabolizing
cell in order to replicate so the
protein-protein interactions at sort of
the lowest level of biological
organization that proximate interaction
can be something that can change on
viruses without any of their control
they could bombard with cells that are
not able to be infected because of a
protein mismatch
so this exerts selection pressure on
viruses to change if possible to enter a
cell type that is changing as well if
you consider multicellular organisms
like humans we have tissues that are not
exactly the same throughout our body
so a virus that enters some tissue type
and then needs to spread to another
tissue has a problem of interacting with
a different cell type so as you move up
the level of biological organization to
the cell itself this also presents a
challenge to viruses and where they can
successfully replicate in the
environment again in hosts such as
humans with innate immune systems and
adaptive immune systems that change over
time this presents an environmental
challenge to viruses to keep up with
those changes and they might be able to
do so through mutational change but the
point is those environments change on
them as well and then if you consider
viruses that infect very different types
of organisms that are not at all closely
related an example would be viruses that
infect a mosquito and have to replicate
in the mosquito mid gut before they go
on to being transmitted to a mammal such
as a Hugh
through a mosquito bite so the necessity
for viruses to replicate in two very
different types of hosts is another
thing that drives the interest of me and
the people in my research group and last
if you consider large-scale changes that
are affecting all organisms in the
environment so-called ecosystem level
changes this is also important for even
the smallest denizens of the planet the
viruses so even though they are very
small in size they can still experience
the challenges of a changing environment
at the ecosystem level so this also
becomes of interest to me to consider
how what viruses keep up if the
environment is changing radically at the
level of eco systems a tool that we
often use in my research is called
experimental evolution and this is
really a way of studying evolution in
action this cartoon shows you the basic
setup of a typical experiment that we
might use in the laboratory where we
begin with an ancestor genotype it might
be an ancestral population but the point
is this single entity is used to found
multiple lineages across different
treatment groups so in this way you
could look at lineages and say treatment
a and the ability for repeated evolution
to occur and lineages that are
independently evolving in the same
environmental challenge by the same
token you can look across treatments to
see whether the actual treatment itself
is affecting how these viruses adapt to
some environmental challenge usually the
duration of these experiments can be
long or short depending on what the
researcher wants to do in this
particular example it's shown 100 plus
generations of evolution in evolution in
action experiments or experimental
evolution one can keep track of certain
traits and how they change over time so
one possibility is to look at this
hypothetically or you have a
distribution of some trait of interest
that's shown here in green on this
hypothetical diagram and as that
population is interacting with an
ecological filter or an environmental
challenge you can literally see a change
in that trait or the mean of that
distribution of trait values through
time
and in these types of experiments we
keep track of time by counting
generations we have access especially in
virus experiments to the entire genome
and to examine it through genomics to
see how does the ancestral genotype
change into those that are adapting
within this experiment to the
environmental challenge and you can
literally sequence the entire genome
pretty efficiently and affordably to
look exhaustively throughout the genome
for where those mutations are occurring
spontaneously that let the populations
better adapt to the environment one
final aspect of these types of
experiments where we hold a lot of power
when you use viruses to conduct them is
that we have an immediate inference
about the phenotype genotype
associations that is we're measuring the
phenotypes rigorously we're looking
exhaustively across the entire genome so
we can immediately make some sort of a
match prediction between the mutations
we see the phenotypes that change and
try to make sense of what's the real
functional role of those mutations now
those experiments are not trivial one
might want to then take the mutation or
mutations that you observe in your
experiment and use further techniques
such as reverse genetics to build those
mutations and one by one into the wild
type ancestor and prove explicitly that
the mutations that were seen in the
experiment are responsible for certain
functional changes in the mutation with
all that power my lab group is able to
address a variety of research topics and
these range from what would could be
defined as basic questions to applied
questions so we have a very general
interest in how evolutionary processes
occur one could cast that as tempo and
mode of evolution and adaptation and
there are lots of handy analogies
especially adaptive landscapes as
depicted in this cartoon to consider as
evolution is happening as new mutations
are brought together into genomes to
account for fitness changes one can
envision this as climbing a fitness peak
to ever an ever higher levels of fitness
and the environment and we can keep
track of that in our experiments more in
terms of the ecology and evolution of
infectious disease in particular we cast
our experiments in this way to perhaps
examine what is the role of direct
transmission of some parasite or
pathogen between host individuals such
as occurs in a human sneeze versus what
is the role of vector transmission where
as I alluded to earlier some viruses and
other pathogens have to replicate in
very different types of organisms and be
transmitted around the environment so
one can cast our experiments in a more
deliberate way to gain insight in how
infectious disease systems interact with
other aspects of the environment that's
their ecology and also how they change
over time that's their evolution and
last for a very applied goal we could
look at viruses and both their
opportunities and abilities to adapt as
well as the constraints that prevent
them from doing so to gain insight into
how do we understand viruses in some
very widespread applications such as
vaccines to control the spread of
disease well we could even gain insight
into viruses and their ability to serve
as new applied routes for therapy so the
latter third of my talk deals a lot with
that topic so here's a rough outline for
what I'd like to cover I'll start in a
very general way in talking about the
evolution of genetic trade-offs this is
something that can be observed in nature
and it drives our curiosity and our
experiments and ultimately I'll show you
a very applied significance of
considering trade-offs in terms of
developing virus applications a very
specific and widespread type of
trade-off is called the survival versus
reproduction trade-off so I'll briefly
cover how that trade-off seems to
operate in all biological systems
including in viruses and I'll end by
considering how evolution thinking
especially those topics that cover
upstream can help us improve virus
applications for some important purpose
and the important purpose that I'll
focus on is the combating of bacterial
especially those that are increasing in
their antibiotic resistance so we are
running out of options to control
certain bacterial diseases and I'll
present how evolution thinking can help
us improve phage therapy as a way of
using viruses to control and kill
bacterial pathogens so let me start with
the evolution of genetic trade-offs a
lot of the research that we do tries to
tackle so-called big questions in
biology and there are fewer questions
any bigger than this one why are there
so many species on earth
a lot of the reasoning behind the
answers to such a question deal with the
fact that evolution involves compromises
often when we go and examine evolving
systems we find that they can't do
everything well so essentially natural
selection as Darwin elucidated so
beautifully in his most famous book On
the Origin of Species
he considered in that book how natural
selection can operate and allow
biological systems become to become
better adapted to their environments and
their environmental challenges but in
doing so they could experience
trade-offs they can improve in one trait
at the expense of performance and
another trait so the graphs in the
middle illustrate this basic idea if you
consider two of probably the most
fundamental things that you could think
of happening in replicating systems and
that is the ability to reproduce as well
as the ability to survive some
environmental perturbation so if a
biological system evolves to invest in
better reproduction it could be that
that environment causes them to suffer
worse survival as a consequence and by
the other token they could improve
improve in one trait in survival and yet
have a liability in their ability to
reproduce so that whole body of work is
often covered in a theoretical way and
one of my colleagues at Yale Steve
Stearns he's one of the main architects
of life history theory and the idea here
is that in general you can look in
biology and find that traits cannot be
simultaneously maximized and that you'll
often find this fundamental trade-off
between survival for
reproduction so the question is would
viruses who even are considered as
nonliving by certain individuals by the
definitions of life do we also see
survival versus reproduction trade-offs
in these systems so let me begin by
starting with the model system where we
examine this question this is a
bacteriophage or a virus that is
specific to bacteria it's called five
six and it infects Pseudomonas in
particular we often grow it in the
laboratory on Pseudomonas syringae path
of ours so these are different species
and subspecies paths of ours of this
bacterium that grow on certain plant
types in nature
we pretty much restrict our studies to
the laboratory but it's nice in terms of
this model system giving us a lot of
power in the lab because we know a lot
about the underlying genetics it has
only 13 KB sized genome so relatively
small and it has its genes separated
across segments within each virus
particle so it has a segmented genome so
those are some of the details of the
genetics of the system more importantly
I'd like you to key in on the diagram
showing the politican fection cycle for
this virus it's fairly typical of
oolitic virus in the sense that these
small red hexagons are showing you the
attachment of a virus particle to a
protein appendage called a pilis that's
extending out from that bacterial cell
this allows the virus to gain entry and
to replicate within the cell using the
molecular machinery of the cell over
time those virus particles in the cell
will mature and the cell bursts open
releasing those particles that can then
go on and infect other cells in the
environment the picture in the middle
shows you these little white visible
phage particles in this particular
picture attached to the type 4 pillars
of the bacteria that are extending out
in that diagram and on the far right we
have a real image of Pseudomonas
syringae bacteria on a leaf surface
where i want you to keep in mind that
the importance of these pill I that the
bacteria has
are to move or traverse across the leaf
surface and to enter the plant through
the stomata through the openings in the
leaves and this allows the bacteria to
gain entry to function as a bacterial
plant pathogen so I'll come back to that
property later but for now I just wanted
to introduce the system as the phage is
called five six and Pseudomonas
especially Pseudomonas syringae bacteria
are the hosts that we study for
infection a fundamental problem that
viruses exist no matter that that they
face no matter where they exist is that
they are not stable for very long
periods and there may be changes in the
environment where they have to
experience selection to improve in their
stability so you can consider stability
to be a survival trait in viruses and
this is a very measurable phenomenon as
shown in this graph so these are data
from a paper in 2008 and here we show
that if you just take lysate soar just
pure viruses placed in solution of this
type and you incubate them for a very
short period of time only five minutes
at an elevated temperature you can
contrast those high temperature
environments and the stability or the
survival of that virus population on
average as they feel this extreme
stressful environment so recall that the
typical environment temperature that we
use in the laboratory is 25 degrees C
and you'll see that if you push the
temperature up to a very high level and
incubate viruses for only five minutes
at a time eventually you'll reach
temperatures of 40 degrees and higher
where you can measure extreme mortality
or very low survival of the average
particles in that lysate so one could
cast this graph as what is typically
called typically called a reaction norm
for the virus under a stressful
condition and that stressful condition
is high temperature well given the
experimental evolution method I
mentioned earlier one might be
interested in can these viruses improve
and their ability to be stable in these
new environments so the way that you
would do
that is shown in the cartoon on the
right you could take a pure lysate of
the virus place it in say a heating
block that was preheated to the correct
temperature in the stressful temperature
place the virus lysate in that
environment for a very short period and
then played it under normal conditions
let the virus then infect the host at 25
degrees C and form plaques as I'll
describe in a moment and the process of
doing this several virus generations
occur through that lytic infection cycle
you can then harvest those viruses put
them back through this experimental
condition and as shown in the circled
temperatures on the Left we've done this
at temperatures as high as 50 degrees
Celsius to see whether these heat shocks
lead to improvement of the ability of
the viruses to withstand that stressful
temperature going immediately to some of
our published data these data come from
a paper in 2012 where what you're seeing
here along the x-axis is increasing
temperature and on the y-axis is this
measurement of mean percent survival
when the viruses experience this
temperature well the real take-home
message of this graph is that in an
experiment where we allowed three
lineages shown in red to experience
these 50 degrees celsius heat shocks for
only five minutes periodically
throughout the experiment they did
improve in their average survival at the
extreme temperature of 50 degrees
Celsius so you may not be impressed by
how much they improved but that average
improvement is statistically significant
and greater than their counterparts
shown in blue that were evolving
alongside them under the exact same
conditions except that they were not
experiencing the 50 degrees Celsius heat
shock they were experiencing a mock
shock at 25 C well the take-home here is
that at the more benign and yet warm
temperatures we have very high survival
observe for those heat shock evolved
lineages in other words they've
broadened their ability to withstand
high temperatures which could be called
environmental robust
but the main point is that they've
improved a lot in their survival under
stressful conditions especially relative
to their counterparts that evolved for
the same period of time but never saw
heat shocks how they did so it's very
important to consider one mutation that
came in to all those heat shock lineages
that did not come into the lineage as
shown in blue and the real difference is
the thermal tolerance of oolitic enzyme
that lets these viruses both enter the
cell they bring this enzyme with them in
order to get into the cell but as those
particles are released they also use
that enzyme to get out they cope the
nucleocapsid and that's held with each
virus particle as it exits the cell as
you can see in the top cartoon the
thermal tolerant lytic enzyme has an
amino acid substitution that fills
what's called a hydrophobic pocket in
that enzyme making it much more durable
or stable under high heat in this
contrast the existing pocket in the
lower cartoon for the wild-type as well
as in those control evolved lineages so
now we have a very simple and elegant
explanation for how these heat-shock
evolve lineages are able to withstand
that stressful environment they did so
with a single mutational change that
allowed them to become more heat shock
tolerant or thermal tolerant
now let's Qian Qian on the trade-off
that comes about when this occurs on the
left now these are data from an
experiment where one can look at the
impact of that one mutation alone for
the reproductive capacity of these
viruses under the normal condition when
they're simply infecting cells at 25
degrees Celsius the blue bar shows you
what is the effect of the wild-type in a
sense when competing against itself for
mean fitness in this ordinary
environment and by definition the mean
Fitness is one whereas the red bar shows
you that this one mutational change was
enough to cause a huge selective
disadvantage or an s value of
approximately zero
point two-five where there is a huge
liability to having evolved heat shock
tolerance for the reduced capacity to
reproduce under normal conditions this
is clearly a genetic trade-off that
spans the two environments and the amino
acid substitution itself could be
abbreviated as v2 o7f meaning that the
valine was substituted by a
phenylalanine at that position and this
causes a life history trade-off between
survival and reproduction finally key in
on this diagram showing a real picture
of what the plaques look like for these
two different types of viruses so the
gray in this image is a confluent
bacterial long meaning that on an agar
plate one can grow bacteria to a very
very high density and then the plaques
or these circles on the lawn are formed
when you take a diluted amount of the
virus and you sprinkle them on the lawn
and you incubate at 25 degrees C and
overnight you will get cells that are
infected by that virus producing progeny
that infect neighboring cells and you
get a little clearing in the lawn that
is a circular kind of a local epidemic
well there's a very big difference
phenotypically or visually between the
plaques that are formed by the wild type
virus those are shown with the blue
arrow and these are clear meaning that
all of the host bacterial cells within
that plaque seem to be dying as this
epidemic is occurring whereas there's a
very different kind of a phenotype for
these v2 o7f or thermal tolerant mutants
where the grayness within the plaque
indicates that many of those cells are
missing dying as a result of the
infection spread of that virus locally
in the plaque in other words they are
visually less productive compared to the
wild type and that's borne out in the
bar diagram directly above the image so
these data relate to an earlier study by
de Pepin today in 2006 where they took
viruses that could all infect ecoli and
they looked at their mortality rate or
sir
rate versus the reproduction rate and
they found a very tight relationship in
other words it echoes the survival
reproduction trade-off that I introduced
for some reason if you look at each of
these phage types they have a
characteristic ability to reproduce a
characteristic mortality rate and they
fall along this very tight relationship
so essentially these researchers do not
know what are the ecological conditions
in the real world that have selected for
these viruses to appear wherever they
appear on this line but you can consider
the experiment I just showed you as
taking any one virus and moving it up
and down the line through the power of
risk of experimental evolution so our
data do relate to this more broad
phenomenon in viruses especially other
phages we've also also shown how it
relates to viruses of eukaryotes but the
main point is that viruses do suffer the
classic survival versus reproduction
trade-offs so let's return again to this
picture that I showed you earlier of how
these viruses infect the bacterial cells
by attaching initially to the type 4
coli that allow the bacteria to function
as plant pathogens so clearly if these
bacteria are experiencing these viruses
in the wild which they occasionally do
one could ask well what selection
pressure is going to be exerted on the
host bacteria and if they see these
phages and they can respond through
natural selection to improve their
ability to withstand phage attack does
that have any obvious consequences does
that ability to resist phage attack have
any thing to do with a trade-off
this is shown in the following diagram
that indeed it does so the resistance of
these bacteria to phage 5:6 one mode of
resistant of resistance has a huge
impact on their virulence so if you
consider in the picture again of these
virus particles attached to pili that
are extended from these bacterial cells
one way for the bacteria to
spontaneously mutate
to avoid phage attack is to simply shed
the pillow they won't have any longer
the primary binding site for the phages
so therefore they will escape infection
well this is all well and good and one
could observe that in the laboratory but
one would expect that that would have a
huge liability in the natural world and
that's because these bacterial pathogens
form in this case a disease called halo
blight especially in being plants so if
you consider the loss of the pilis that
prevents the ability for the bacteria to
traverse the leaves and get into the
plant interestingly if you just put the
bacteria directly in the plant they will
happily function as pathogens so in
other words the pill I themselves and
their loss this can be considered a
conditional variance factor because they
cannot traverse the leads naturally but
they're still infectious in the sense of
being able to infect and replicate
within the plant but that clearly is an
evolutionary trade-off one way to
summarize that is that the phage
selection in this particular system can
lower bacterial pathogen isset II by
experiencing the phages and if the
result is that mutants of these bacteria
are favored who shed the pill I entirely
well that is one way to escape phage
attack but it makes them necessarily
worse pathogens all right so the way
that I'm going to link this to our
current work in phage therapy is that we
had been working in the system for some
period of time noticing this effect of
phage selection on lowering the
bacterial pathogen isset II and we
thought how might this phenomenon inform
our ability to choose better candidates
for phage therapy so we can ask the
question can phage therapy exploit
evolutionary trade-offs so let me begin
by reminding the audience of the very
familiar problem an unfortunate one is
that antibiotic resistance is spreading
in bacterial populations we've observed
this for decades and it's still
occurring this means that first line
antibiotics are becoming less useful as
the prevalence of multi-drug resistant
bacteria increase on the planet these
MDR or multi drug-resistant bacteria and
a good example of them is Pseudomonas
aeruginosa it's particularly worrisome
for cystic fibrosis patients severe burn
victims and in general for any immune
compromised patient the problem is that
Pseudomonas aeruginosa is very readily
found even within our own homes it's in
soils it's in kitchen sink trains it's
everywhere around us so
opportunistically this pathogen could
enter the human body and depending on
your physiology or your disease state it
can be very worrisome for your health
and sometimes deadly the real problem
with antibiotic resistance spread in the
system is that these bacteria have a
complex of proteins called efflux pumps
as shown in the diagram here a very
simple way to conceive of this is it is
it is several proteins roughly three of
them that function as transport protein
complexes that if the antibiotics
permeate within the cell they're
effectively pumped out through these e
flux pumps and these function very
generally may not only do these efflux
pumps function a variety of things for
the cell itself including disease
related things like host colonization
for certain tissues avoiding host
immunity and forming tight assemblages
of bacteria called biofilms but they
simply can easily function to pump out
antibiotics across a wide range of
antibiotic classes so the e flux pumps a
little more on them they're typically
chromosome encoded and genetically
conserved they're generally found in
gram-negative bacteria and as I alluded
to a moment ago they are major
determinants of resistance for different
classes including amino glycosides
macrolides
and tetracyclines so within Pseudomonas
aeruginosa this is a very worrisome
problem that you see the increase of
multi drug-resistant genotypes in the
system and they do have important health
relevance what are we going to do about
it
so many people around the world are at
researching to find ways to treat
bacterial infections aside from the old
traditional routes if we find that
antibiotics are failing what other
options might we have well interestingly
we have an old idea that's been still
studied in certain parts of the world
but wasn't ever very popular in Western
medicine and that is a concept known as
phage therapy the Russians were the
first ones to develop this idea but it
also was popular in countries such as
Poland long ago and even predating the
discovery of antibiotics accidentally by
Alexander Fleming so the idea here is
that you would find a phage that is
specific to your disease bacterial
target and you essentially develop this
phage as a drug so it will find and kill
the bacteria that it is supposed to kill
and be incapable of killing other
bacteria including those that are
beneficial to your health and might
exist within your microbiome now that we
know much more about that phenomenon but
as long as as long ago as world war ii
russian soldiers were sometimes
outfitted with a small vial of phages
that they might use in the field if they
were wounded why because their wound
could be colonized by a bacterial
infection that might hurt or even kill
them before they were able to reach
someplace where they could get health
some help from a health physician so
that's one age-old example but even
recently when you consider certain
bacterial infections and diseases
especially cholera we know already that
clean water and rehydration therapy is
essential for trying to save a cholera
victim but if you administer phages that
are specific to these cholera bacteria
as well
this can also hasten their ability to
recover from a cholera disease infection
so we have some good news but frankly we
need more data to figure out how
beneficial is phage therapy and would
any old candidate work in terms of
finding a phage that'll do the job well
we didn't think so well we wanted to
look specifically for
and phages with certain properties that
should be able to do the job better so
consider the following if you think of a
genetic trade-off as being widely spread
in nature and I tried to convince you of
that earlier how might it impact our
ability to improve antimicrobial therapy
here again is one of those typical
cartoons for a little phase infection
and this infection cycle if you have
phages infecting bacteria as I mentioned
in the 5/6 and Pseudomonas syringae
example what you expect is the following
that if possible these mutants and the
bacterial population will be favored
that are incapable of being infected by
the phages here I'm showing a change in
the exterior proteins of the cell on the
right now shown in blue and this is
presenting the incapable ability of
these phages to get in and kill the
bacteria well suppose what came along
with that was somehow an increased
sensitivity to antibiotics in other
words as a result of changing through
mutation to avoid phage attack there was
something that made these cells more
vulnerable to antibiotics that would be
terrific for phage therapy and the
reason is that it would first give us an
option to do the antimicrobial therapy
itself and also if it is sort of
reinvigorating our ability to use
antibiotics that are no longer useful
then we can extend the lifetime of
current antibiotics in our so called
arsenal and this is the kind of time
that we need in terms of the spread of
multi drug-resistant bacteria on the
planet we may find new solutions but
ideally this kind of a genetic trade-off
felt by the bacteria would let us go
back to an old solution and revive that
at least for some period of time so this
is exactly what we found and I'll go
through the next series of slides too to
prove to you that this was the case we
found in nature a phage abbreviated as
om ko1 on the family Maya very day and
these linux aids were found to bind to
the outermost proteins for certain
effects pumps especially opr in
extends beyond the cell surface and is
available as a phage binding target we
confirmed this using a series of
knockout bacterial genotypes from a
collection observe obtained from
University of Washington but the point
here is that the phage was able to
infect all of those bacterial mutants
except the ones that had a knockout of
the O PRM meaning that it did not
present this binding target on the cell
so we discovered in sequenced this virus
relatively recently in 2016 here at Yale
and it has some very interesting
properties when the phage sensitive
bacterial population is that is normally
able to eat flux antibiotics they are
killed by this phage in other words the
phage binds enters and replicates and
kills the bacteria the fade-resistant
mutants have an impaired ability to e
flux antibiotics meaning that they are
now vulnerable to some drugs that are
more or less useless in the system and
they become useful again where we found
this phage is interesting we simply
looked in water samples in a nearby lake
called dodge pond here in Connecticut so
we had no idea whether the phages would
reside in this lake that had these
particular properties but the point is
because we brought them into the lab and
put them through a particular screening
process we were able to find these very
intriguing phage candidates so a little
bit more on how this phage operates and
what we observe when we bring it into
the laboratory so again the evolution of
Pseudomonas originals our resistance to
this phage causes sensitivity to certain
drugs the so called desired trade-off
that I presented earlier so what does
that actually look like when you measure
it in the laboratory consider this auger
plate which has a confluent lawn of
bacteria on it and one could place a
small disc containing a drug at some
high level of density that then spreads
out on the plate and whatever level of
that drug that the bacteria can grow to
they can sometimes grow up right to the
edge of in this case a Kirby Bower disc
so these multi drug-resistant
teria pretty much shrug off the effects
of that drug and they have no zone of
inhibited growth but at the lower
portion of this picture it shows you
that one mutational step away when these
bacterial populations are exposed to the
phage those that are able to survive
because they are spontaneous mutants
they have a very clear and different
minimum inhibitory concentration in
other words you readily observe this
large killing zone indicating that they
are now more sensitive to antibiotics
looking a little closer at this
phenomenon I'm going to present a table
that summarizes a lot of information but
it was presented in our 2016 paper let's
begin with considering two antibiotics
for which there is very rock solid
evidence from the literature and prior
experiments that tetracycline and a RIF
Meissen from these two different classes
shown in the second column tetracyclines
and macrolides we know that e flux pumps
function to allow Pseudomonas aeruginosa
to be resistant to those drugs so if you
look at on average the isolates for a
variety of bacterial strains and their
minimum inhibitory concentration when
you expose them to the phage and you
find resistant mutants to the phage you
get a very different mi see for these
strains shown here as an average value
and one can look in the final column at
the fold increased drug sensitivity and
you find that this is a very impressive
change that is exerted completely by the
phage being in the environment and
causing either the bacteria to die or
for those that survive to be much more
vulnerable to these two drugs now one
can consider four other drugs from four
other in this case actually three other
classes and you'll see the changes in mi
C and the fold increased drug
sensitivity and you may not be as
impressed by those numbers they're not
as large of a of a change however I'm
showing with the asterisks that at these
levels the change is relevant from a
clinical resistance to susceptibility
breakpoint meaning that we have now four
six total drugs that I'm showing you in
this tape
very good evidence that in this case
these four drugs in the middle we know
that II flux pumps function most of the
time in determining resistance maybe not
all the time as in the top two drugs on
the table but now we've got six
different instances for a variety of
bacterial strains all Pseudomonas
originals clinical isolates that this is
working very well when they feel the
exertion the selection pressure exerted
by the phage now last as a control
consider a drug like ampicillin so this
is in the class of penicillins where
multi drug efflux pumps do not function
in turn in terms of determining the
resistance well not surprisingly we got
no change between the mi see pre and
post phage exposure so that control in a
sense worked very well and it is very
consistent with the rest of the data
that I presented so the summation of
this is that only drugs exported by
multi drug efflux pumps are affected in
this analysis let's look at one more
data set that is so far unpublished but
if one wants to bring a little more
reality into this you could consider
that Pseudomonas aeruginosa and many
other bacterial pathogens something else
that's very difficult in terms of even
delivering antibiotics if they did work
is that they form these structures
called biofilms which are very resilient
to anything getting into this tight
network of cells and the matrix that
they exist within because of what's
extruded from these cells binding them
together so shown in this diagram if you
if you expose a biofilm to antibiotics
shown in and one color here in red you
don't expect them to get in in other
words the biofilm is resilient to that
but some phages including om ko1 have
the ability to get into the biofilm and
destroy it and expose those cells some
of them to antibiotics so you have a
synergistic effect
so these unpublished data are very
interesting in the sense that they
suggest the interaction between the
phage and this antibiotic have a better
killing power than either the phage and
the antibiotic alone under many
Constance's so what we did was to
consider four very popular types of
material and that might go into the
human body through surgery increasingly
so in terms of popular things that are
put into the body to help make our
organs functioning again when they've
worn down so if you consider the black
bars in this diagram this is what
happens when the bacterial densities in
these biofilms are exposed to certain
antibiotics ceftazidime and
ciprofloxacin then the two other colored
bars here next to them that basically
you see no effect of these antibiotics
when you expose the bacteria in these
biofilms on these different substrates
to those two drugs however in each set
of data the bar on the Left shown in
darker gray this is when you take phage
on ko1 and expose those biofilms on
these substrates to the phage alone you
get a much reduced density of cells as a
result and that's very promising from
the action of the phage alone but now
consider especially those bars that have
asterisks over them this is when you
combine the phage and the antibiotic to
get a better and a more synergistic
killing so these are also very promising
data because they suggest that if a
bacterial biofilm for a multi drug
resistant bacterium is forming on some
artificial part of the body that through
surgery has been altered these are great
substrates for biofilms to form and now
we're demonstrating that this
synergistic effect between the phage and
the drug might be enough to clear such
very tough and resilient infections and
that would be excellent for the outcome
for the patient so what do we do next in
the system I'll end by talking about
some future work and applications first
of all the trade-off in the table that I
showed you and our other work is very
promising in the sense that we've
observed the same phenomenon for a
variety of laboratory model strains for
clinical isolates from a variety of
sources
and even for multi drug-resistant
bacteria that are taken directly from
the environment they might be in a human
home or an estuary and still be multi
drug-resistant and in a sense we get
essentially the same outcome so the
objective now is to look even wider look
at very large clinical isolate
repositories to make sure that this good
news extends even beyond the large
number of strains that we've looked at
with the approval of the US Food and
Drug Administration we are seeking to
treat chronically infected human
volunteers we've actually done that with
one volunteer patient who had an aortic
arch replacement so this was an
artificial part of his heart that his
physicians later found out was colonized
after surgery by this opportunistic
pathogen pseudomonas aeruginosa such
that by the time he was feeling very ill
effects and they observed this very
massive biofilm formation around his
heart there was very little to nothing
they could do for him because he
happened to be of an age where if they
took that part out and put another
artificial part in he probably would not
have survived that surgery he
volunteered for the experimental
treatment using the phage that I
described and we are currently in the
process of publishing his successful
case study already if you want to hear
more about it you can find out through a
public radio international piece that we
did for Science Friday in 2016 and
various other radio spots and some
online news describing this case study
so it was a very promising outcome and
yet in a sense we want to take a big
step backward that we were fortunate
that we helped a human volunteer but
Ohno narrowly somebody would get to this
point after a large amount of saying
Mouse studies in the laboratory in a
controlled way and that's exactly what
we are attempting currently so our
objective is to look at the safety and
efficacy at a mouse model for lung
pneumonia and immune compromised
patients so this can be mimicked in
Mouse populations in the laboratory
we were fortunate to receive an NIH
preclinical services award in 2017 and
these experiments are underway I don't
have very many results to show you so
far but I can give you a little glimpse
of something that is related to these
experiments and some good news about how
this phage operates when it's inside of
the largely black box of a live animal
and trying to cure these infections
through this therapy so what this graph
shows is one can consider this phage
that we grow up in the laboratory on a
typical model strain pa-o 1 and in the
sense of these mouse experiments the
pathogenic strain that is actually used
is abbreviated as un CD well this graph
is showing you that how well does this
phage grow in the laboratory on this
this model strain versus the one that's
a pathogenic strain and the grey points
on this diagram show you that the fades
grows much better on the model strain
when we produce it in the laboratory
compared to when we challenged it to
grow on that pathogenic strain whereas
those data shown here in red and blue
are from mouse tissues from infected
mice experimentally infected mice but
the pathogen that were then treated with
the phage and saves through the process
we find that in a very short time period
these are only three day long acute
pneumonia models in the laboratory these
phage taken from the live animals now
grow orders of magnitude better on that
pathogenic strain than they do on the
host strain that we grew them up on
before we provided them to the
researchers who did these experiments
okay so the main point here is that this
is an amazing amount of phenotypic
improvement for this phage in the system
it's a DNA phage we don't think that it
has a particularly high mutation rate
just a standard mutation rate that you
would see in a DNA phage and yet in the
circumstance in the therapy itself the
phages dramatically improved in their
ability to kill the target bacteria
that's good news for phage therapy as
well so our broader
objectives that I'll end with is to
continue the kind of clinical
applications that we seek to conduct in
a wide variety of systems
hospital-acquired pneumonia cystic
fibrosis associated pulmonary infections
catheter-associated UTIs and burns so we
are now seeking approval to do
investigational new drug status for this
phage and to help a lot of people and to
examine how this page operates in a real
clinical trial and the mouse experiments
help get us closer to that goal very
last thing I'll say is that honestly we
thought we would make faster strides in
agricultural settings because there are
fewer regulatory hurdles there so this
is a reminder that in a lot of the food
that we make on farms increasingly these
are on large and large farms to feed a
hungry world and an example would be
shrimp that is farmed largely in Asia
and then distributed around the world
well there can be outbreaks bacterial
diseases in these farm settings that
destroy the shrimp or make them
unpalatable to be sold to for example
stores and restaurants
so of course industry in those types of
settings or plant agricultural settings
they would be interested in the ability
of phages to solve their problems
with multi drug-resistant bacteria as
well so we hope to partner with
agricultural industrial settings to try
and examine how this might actually help
food resources as well so I'd like to
end by acknowledging the individuals who
did the work for the studies that I
presented in general I'd like to thank
my lab members my current lab members
are shown here in the picture and the
main architects for the phage therapy
work that I described I'd like to thank
Ned Chan who is research assistant
research sorry research scientist at my
laboratory so he's a senior postdoc
working with me John Wirtz he's also
here Yale in the coli genetic stock
Center he's a longtime collaborator of
mine and worked on these experiments
with us and I'm especially grateful to
dr. Deepak Nam
who is at Yale School of Medicine and he
was the surgeon who collaborated with us
on this work just above him we have a
picture of Ben and me thanking the
patient who volunteered for the study
and the volunteer therapy experimental
therapy that we conducted thankfully
this worked he is back at work so we are
visiting him in his workplace and you
might be able to make out that we gave
him a thank you card as well as a sage
plush toy so I'm not trying to sell
those items but we had a lot of fun
thanking him and he really was very
brave to undergo this experimental
treatment and last I'd like to thank the
funders for the work NIH NSF Yale itself
project high hopes has been a great
funder of our work in the past few years
and the NSF beacon Center for evolution
in action and I'd like to thank you for
your attention I look forward to
answering any questions via email that
you might have for me and I genuinely
hope that you enjoyed the presentation